when Japan faced its own banking and
debt crisis in the 1990s the first thing
it did is it started to lower the its
target interest rate or the rate that
banks borrow reserves from each other
and the way to do that is you print
money in the case of Japan the central
bank prints yen it buys short-term
government securities but the byproduct
of that is that it increases the amount
of currency or reserves in circulation
all banks have more reserves so the
demand for that reserves will go down or
the cost of borrowing it will go down
and so it lowers the interest rate but
Japan did that enough so they got to a
zero percent interest rate but then it
really couldn't lower that interest rate
anymore that's exactly what Bernanke is
faced with the u.s. credit crisis so the
next thing that Japan said is ok we
still want more money to enter into
circulation so we're going to keep
printing we're going to keep printing
more yen we're going to keep printing
more yen but since it's really of no use
just to buy the short-term debt anymore
because we've already kind of priced
those as high as we can we've lowered
short-term interest rates as much as
possible let's use this stuff to buy
other things let's just get this money
into circulation any which way we can
so let's buy long-term Japanese
Treasuries let's buy let's buy corporate
debt so they did buy a bunch of stuff
but their intention was literally just
to increase the quantity to increase the
quantity of money so what the Japanese
did was kind of pure quantitative easing
they were trying to print money at any
cost and let that money go into
circulation in any which way as possible
and they would buy a bunch of stuff to
do it
what Bernanke is doing mechanically is
not that different than what the
Japanese did he started off trying to
lower short-term interest rates so who
would buy short-term securities it would
increase the amount of reserves in
circulation lower the overnight
borrowing rate lower the federal funds
rate but when that went to 0%
so they both hit they both hit this
floor at 0% Bernanke's like well how do
I solve the log jam in the credit
markets and Bernanke just like Japan
says well I'm going to start printing
more money and I'm going to use it to
buy assets that the Fed does not
traditionally
I and Japan did this as well the
difference and this is how Bernanke
explains the difference is he doesn't
view this as pure quantitative easing
not because it's mechanically different
because it really is mechanically the
same thing but he calls it credit easing
and in his mind the difference between
quantitative and credit easing is the
intent and where you do direct that
extra money that you've printed in in
Japanese Japanese case they printed
money for the sake of printing money and
they bought all of this stuff just to
get that money into circulation in
Bernanke's case he is printing money he
who does want that money in circulation
but that's not the end that he's trying
to achieve the end is is to increase
demand for some of these types of
securities where maybe there's a log jam
so the different even though
mechanically they're saying Bernanke
says this is credit easing because I'm
trying to fix a problem in the
commercial debt market or I'm trying to
fix a problem in the mortgage-backed
security market while Japan was just
trying to print money for the sake of
printing money